siamo in partenza per la sicilia
e adesso abbiamo dodici ore per arrivare
a napoli e quindi niente ho pregato il
rito qui dormi tu dormi muoviti
un'inquadratura bellissima cosa state
combinando da mandato questo biglietto
d'auguri a tutte le persone che abbiamo
conosciuto quest'anno ad alcuni amici
agenti e li stiamo personalizzato per
che babbo natale
vedi la l'intero devo chiedere una
cortesia
state attenti ai pandori questi pandori
in qualsiasi che già hanno schiacciato
qualcuno e gr arrabbiatissima
sì sì perché ha detto non li spiaccicate
errico la presolana ancora non parla di
una cosa e sostituisce la fattura
terrorismo psicologico su quanto che
sarebbe stato il praticabile
l'autostrada e cose così
ora non so se sono le vostre preghiere
ma sappiate che questa situazione
avevano previsto verbo
ragazzi mio padre sta per morire perché
già papà ti amava tanto vale che ieri
sabato 12 ore
cosa avete unite occhi da è che la
strada è un po ventilato diciamo però
bene conciarie di pioggia però deve
riuscire a togliere il cappotto con che
ma senti già caldo di 24 ore il 45 per
villa san giovanni ci metterei la firma
ad esso è attento i panettoni lavinia
come cuscino l'hai tu che non ha vissuto
questo pupazzo di neve ma sai cosa di
sbagliato
hai sbagliato che cosa hai fatto giusto
la domanda cosa appena successo che ho
mandato intanto delle cose dove la vita
non era fucsia resterà mera marroni
diciamola tutta tu pensavi fosse tutti
sia per chi la vide ha detto mi piace
come disse marroni arriva dopo averlo
forza anche riprese di voi davanti
solamente stiamo andando a catania sono
state costrette di miu miu canale enrico
per perdere l'uscita per salerno grazie
a qualcuno non so chi marco d'accordo
salerno un folletto
[Musica]
bene parte la pioggia il tempo di me
ieri un nemico il jack proposito dovrà
fare la partita di rugby ragusa il
pulmino della sua squadra
a roma si è fatto roma ragusa ci hanno
messo 16 ore il giorno dopo aver giocato
la partita vinta e dopo la partita di
tori incamminati verso roma
[Musica]
dopo si sapeva che sono lento sarebbe
arrivato a bari la ti bre niente in
confronto a quello che c'è
chissà come sono un po di macchine prima
del casello dove vanno a lavorare dove
parcheggiano e sei un casellante o amico
di casellante apparente di casellante
potreste darmi questa risposta per farsi
non posso dire una cosa importantissima
facciamo vedere le persone come si
supera un casello di sky cinema storia
tocca avere un braccio abbastanza lungo
in realtà grazie deve vederci ma non ci
ha dato di civico
curioso da casa gli amici in santa pace
ciao ragazzi ci fermiamo andiamo
direttamente il campo tra un muro di
volte
sono staccando la notte infatti la video
salumi nando di chiedere scusa
giochiamo al gioco quello lì dell'intesa
bisogna dire una parola
io insieme a selvino bicicletta
io pur avere detto bicicletta
scarsellino moto2
alice lo sapete lo facciamo io gianmarco
23 azzurro azzurro cielo azzurro il
colore della pelle ma noi abbiamo fatto
un cambio al volante
ora siamo io e la vita davanti e i due
magnati dietro che si sarebbe detto vi
state vedendo ragazzo morto poi
guardiamo una cosa importantissima
gianmarco enrico tifano juve il fratello
gabriele tifa lazio quindi stasera sarà
una notte non sarà una notte lunga dove
qualcuno avrà vinto qualcuno avrà perso
chi avrà vinto non sarà impietoso chi ha
perso e viceversa
altra cosa si può mangiare bene voglio
fare io arrivai fatta la bbc guidando
come il grande mago
io ringrazio la linea star ball andrà
via
diciamo solo che siamo perché siamo a
parte ci sono le scale mobili del
traghetto ma una squadra di rugby
la linea un commento sulla squadra di
rugby rocco in boots di mare a vita
allora siamo sbarcati la vita
arrabbiatissima con noi intanto perché
non abbiamo fatto un video non potete
vedere dell'arancino mangiate buio
profilo è un cane fatto il male
sembra che l'attore enrico è un
coniglietto stai cercando di fare aiuto
ma stai cercando di fare niente
questo è un classico è uno struzzo
anche oggi è finita
siamo grati alla fine del viaggio
mancano solo si è buttata e ragazzi dai
3 set è un problema mio ma per me è
appena iniziata dalla tavola abbiamo
voluto nei giochi del ma l'episodio due
utility apple non ha voluto invece un
passante e credenti ma ci vediamo domani
con una puntata penultima puntata di
ieri di fare divertire alla penultima
puntata minchiate sono fidati
avvertirete allora ragazzi
un ultima cosa prima di mettermi a
dormire che che penso da belle notti in
realtà allora praticamente questo
viaggio mi ha fatto riflettere tanto
magari ha fatto riflettere tanto stare
in macchina mi ha fatto riflettere tanto
sa cosa è successo ieri notte ora non so
se l'avete letto però ieri notte due
ragazze di 16 anni sono state investite
da un ragazzo viventi allora io sono
passato nel posto dove sono state
investite 30 40 minuti dopo che è
successo e ho beccato tutto ce n'è stato
beccato il post ho visto delle immagini
abbastanza forte e per tutto il tempo mi
sono chiesto come è successo come non è
successo così è successo è successo che
anche poi oggi non ho letto il
notiziario
noi oggi abbiamo fatto un viaggio di
850 chilometri lungo un certo punto ha
grandinato ha piovuto e sicuramente la
quello che ci circonda a volte rende
difficile andare in malattia
ora non voglio entrare nel discorso di
questo incidente mentre in un discorso
un pochino più ampio ossia raga fate
attenzione quando state alla guida punto
veramente infatti c'è attenzione stare
attenti stare attenti quando starà guida
ma soprattutto quando anche non state
alla guida non pensate che le persone di
vedano non pensate che se è verde deve
stare tranquilli attraversare non
pensate in dieci
non fidatevi degli altri quando si
tratta della strada per cassata può
essere molto pericoloso e lui è stata la
guida fate attenzione ragazzi non metti
deve la guida se avete solo se avete
bevuto se vi siete fatti una canna
qualsiasi cosa stateci attenti state
attenti perché basta un secondo basta
una piccola causata che magari avete
fatto 40 mila volte che può essere
attraversare non ci sono le strisce può
essere
la strada che puoi conoscere
perfettamente che ogni volta
prendete contromano perché tanto non
passa nessuno non lo fate non lo fate
perché vi rovinate la vita illuminate la
vita quello che ho visto ieri è stato
cioè è veramente è una roba pesante è
una roba pesante
pioveva e non vorrei assegnerà famiglia
né di questo ragazzone soprattutto di
queste due ragazze che hanno personalità
in questo modo
fate attenzione fate attenzione ma non
fate sì che sia una cosa così passeggera
perché gli spauracchi dopo un po perdono
forza e se ne vanno e perdono potenza
quindi dopo un po si torna a fare come
prima
sappiate che la strada è pericolosa
le macchine sono pericolose e sono dei
mezzi possa essere usate in maniera
cauta o fortemente incauta o ancora
peggio in maniera passiva e quando non
si attenti si rischia veramente di
distruggersi e distruggere gli altri
dovevo dirlo